all right as he's Peter said I'm Arjun
Prasad and on the path to detection team
at ncbi and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about how to get access to
our data in Google cloud and uh how to
work with it a little bit but before I
get there I wanted to tell you a little
bit about where the data comes from and
how it's generated so we have a whole
genome shotgun sequence of isolates that
are submitted by collaborators at the
FDA CDC USDA state and local Public
Health Labs International Public Health
Labs basic researchers clinical sources
Etc they submit their um whole genome
shotgun sequence data to the SRA and
then when we know about it we pick it up
in our pipeline
um so what is that pipeline trying to do
that has two primary goals to answer the
question are these isolates clonally
related could they be part of the same
point source outbreak or or things like
that and then the other is to identify
the antimicrobial resistance genes and
point mutations to assist with AMR
surveillance and research and we present
the results of this pipeline an easy to
use web interface and importantly for
this talk on Google Cloud
so how do we do that
um a very brief overview of the pipeline
is that we take the whole genome shotgun
sequence data from the SRA and we
assemble it with our in-house developed
assemblers that I'll tell you a little
bit about in a moment and then we
cluster those assemblies uh by comparing
them to all the other assemblies for the
same taxonomic group in our system as
well as any other assemblies we can find
for the same taxonomic group in genbank
and then we cluster them into these
groups of very closely related organisms
and within each of those clusters we
infer phylogenic trees at the same time
we're doing that we annotate and run AMR
finder plus and I'll tell you a little
bit more about Hammer finder plus as
well and that is how we identify
antimicrobial resistance genes point
mutations virulence and stress
resistance genes so first about our
assemblers we use two assemblers skiza
and saute the first schiza is a high
accuracy high-speed de novo assembler
um and this was developed uh to to make
the clustering less likely to have
errors because it makes very few errors
in the assembly most other assemblers
are really trying to increase your
contact length and so uh they can make
sometimes uh leaps that are a little too
far in joining uh context
um whereas schiza uh it basically just
assembles along until it comes to a part
that's difficult to assemble where it
thinks it might make a mistake and then
it just stops so that means that it's
the context can be a little bit shorter
and uh to increase sensitivity we also
use the saute a guided assembler so this
is a high sensitivity assembler that can
pull apart alleles based on variants
represented in at least two reads so
if you had a well-known carbopenamous
Gene like kpc2
um and we so we have isolates that have
like a kpc2 and kpc3 uh both of these
are can only be one nucleotide apart
um and saute is able to pull apart those
multiple copies and and if that organism
had two different genes that were only
one nucleotide apart we get the two
different genes
um the guides for the saute assembler
are made from AMR genes and STX
um so what this means is that our
assemblies are made up of the schiza de
novo assemblies uh with the saute guided
assemblies added on and so that means
that our assemblies in genbank will
often include duplicated contacts
um and you could tell them or the
contigs are usually duplicated where
there's an AMR Gene that was uh
assembled by the Satay guided assembler
and you could tell those contacts apart
because the the ones uh assembled by
skiza will have de novo in the name and
the ones assembled by saute will have
guided in the name and we'll see an
example of that in a little bit now uh
to tell you a little bit more about AMR
finder plus it identifies acquired AMR
genes known AMR Associated point
mutations plus some intrinsic AMR genes
and relevant stress and virulence genes
for some taxa and what makes AMR finder
plus different from a lot of other
antimicrobial resistance Gene finding
software well there's a number of things
but I think the biggest thing is that it
makes an affirmative statement as to
what the gene should be called so AMR
finder plus is really trying to give the
sequence the name that one of our
curators would give it if they were
looking at it manually so if you had a
kpc2 as I mentioned which is a named
beta lactamase allele only sequences
that are 100 identical at the amino acid
level would be named kpc2 if there's any
variation at all we'll tell you that
it's either another named allele or that
it's an unnamed allele we'll just call
it block KPC so how does this uh the how
do we present these results well in
Google Cloud we have two primary outputs
from this analysis pipeline we have the
isolates browser where every row is an
isolate genome and columns are metadata
provided by submitters are calculated
based on the genome assembly and I'm
going to show you these very briefly in
our web interface to to give you some
orientation we also have Micro biggie
the microbial browser for the
identification of genetic and genomic
elements and here every row is a gene or
point mutation that was identified by
AMR finder Plus
columns are metadata about the isolate
or gene or point mutation or how it was
found
um and or the the reference sequences in
our database and this contains results
from public assemblies in genbank so
when we assemble things they may first
appear in the isolates browser and then
we submit to genbank and there's some
delays and sometimes some QC issues that
mean that not everything makes it into
micro biggie so there will be a slightly
smaller number of isolates there so I'm
going to switch over to web browser and
show you real quick our web interface
this is the path and detection home page
and I'm going to go over here to the
icelots browser
and I'm going to type in
a search for Enoki I'm just picking this
because there were a couple of recent
outbreaks of listeria that was from uh
contaminating enoki mushrooms and so
here you can see this is the main table
View and here every row is an isolate
assembly and every column is information
about that assembly so here isolation
Source you can see fresh enoki mushrooms
um you could see this was isolated in
Taiwan uh these are the clusters of
closely related organisms we can click
into those and you can see the trees and
you can see here there's environmental
isolate and a clinical isolate they're
closely related so you can see how this
can be used to investigate outbreaks but
I'm not going to tell you too much more
about that the other thing I wanted to
show you is micro biggie so I'm going to
go into micro Biggie and look at these
the genes and point mutations identified
by AMR finder Plus in those isolates so
here you can see this is micro biggie
every row is a gene or point mutation I
can zoom in a little bit and every
column is information about that either
information about the isolate the
element that was found so these are the
gene symbols here
um or how how the isolate was found by
Mr finder Plus
all right so that's all I was going to
show you uh in our web interface uh now
let's get to the Cloud
um so we are using uh Google bigquery to
present these tables in the cloud and
what is it it's a managed SQL database
on Google Cloud it is designed to easily
and quickly allow you to search large
public databases so why are we using it
well we have a large database we want to
make public and in this way we can give
you bulk access to all 21 million rows
of micro biggie including the updates
that we do uh every day
and it also has uses standard SQL query
syntax so you can do complex queries and
Analysis just in Google bigquery without
have to having to download anything
Google has a quite extensive
documentation on bigquery I have some
links here and we have a number of
example queries in our documentation and
if you are trying to figure out how to
use this and and you've looked at these
resources and still uh can't figure out
how to get the information you want you
can feel free to email us at PD Dash
help ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
um so I don't have time to teach you all
about SQL there's a lot of uh good
resources on the web to learn SQL but uh
in case it's new to you I wanted to just
give you a little few little lamp posts
about how things work
um so SQL queries are kind of separated
into separate sections and one of those
is the select clause which tells you
which Fields you want to get from the
the uh tables or from the query
um the from statement says where you
want to get the data from
um and importantly because SQL is uh or
bigquery is a relational database that
means that you can link multiple tables
on shared Fields so you can join and
we'll see an example of that uh in a
minute the where Clause tells you which
results you want give me the results
that that meet these constraints we'll
also use Group by which is how you
cluster results we use it for counting
you can use it for statistics things
like that so this just clusters all the
the groups of rows um
uh into a group
um and order by to sort the results
um there are a number of SQL operators
uh some of the ones you may be familiar
with are the normal ones greater than
equal to less than they work as you
would expect there's also the like
operator which allows you to search with
wild cards so this
um in this case the percent is kind of
the equivalent of a star in Linux or dos
there's also an unnest we'll see an
unnest function which is used to flatten
a repeated field so even if you're
familiar with SQL you may not have come
across a nest before
uh we'll see in a minute but Google
bigquery allows you to have uh fields
that can contain multiple values and
those values can even have multiple
field subfields within them and and
we'll see this but unnest allows you to
just flatten them out and treat them
like a table
so
let's go to the Google Cloud Web
interface uh here is when you get to
Google Cloud you if you type up bigquery
um in the first uh Cloud interface you
can click over here and you'll get to
the bigquery web interface
now the first thing I'm going to do is
add a data source I'm going to start a
project and
all of our data that we're going to
present is in this project and CBI
pathogen detect and so if we star this
then it appears over here and we can use
that to kind of browse it and see some
more information about it about it so
um this is the information is in the PD
browser database and these are the
tables that we have there
um here you can see the isolates table
and the micro biggie table there's also
this isolate exceptions which I'm not
going to tell you much about except that
that's uh for uh QC check failures and
reports those results but if you click
on any of these tables you can see their
structure here's the schema which is
just the the fields that are available
there and here this AST phenotypes field
is one of those complex Fields I was
mentioning where it's a record field
which means it has multiple uh kind of
sub fields and it's repeated so there
can be multiple entries and and we'll
see what that looks like you can also
click on micro Biggie and see things
there there's a tab up here with more
details about any of the tables so here
you can see there's 21 million rows in
micro biggie right now
um and you can preview and see what the
data actually looks like so here you can
see some of the entries in the table
okay so let us start running some
queries
so kind of to start simple here's a
query just to say uh give me some
information about a specific isolate if
I had an isolate I was interested in so
we're going to select and these are the
fields we want to get back from and then
in bigquery uh tables are they're
indicated by putting the table name with
the full Paths of the table in backtick
so that's the key above the tab on on us
keyboards and so ncbi pathogen
detectives the project as I already
mentioned PD browser is the database and
isolates is the table
um so we want the rows in there where
biosample accession is equal to this and
all you have to do is get the results is
Click run
and you get those results and so you can
see here this is one of those repeated
Fields there's multiple values for this
Row in that field
okay let's do
um something else so this is very
similar to what we did before in the
browser we looked for Enoki but here
we're going to count the results so this
is just the way you count things in SQL
um and we're going to get the ice um
from the isolates table uh where the
isolation source is like percent and no
key percent so that just means zero more
characters of any kind followed by Enoki
followed by zero or more characters of
any kind
um and so when you do this uh this will
identify any isolates or count any
isolates where Enoki appears anywhere in
the isolation Source field
so we click run and we get that there's
246. now if you were really eagle-eyed
you might have noticed this number
doesn't exactly match what I showed you
before and that's because these searches
are case sensitive so if we there
sometimes there's a capital E and Enoki
so if we just shortened it like this and
click run again you'll see we get a
larger number so there were some times
when the person who submitted the
isolate capitalized the word Enoki
so let's look uh at some things a little
more complicated
um
so say we want to find contigs that have
a lot of AMR genes so uh antimicrobial
resist genes often come on contacts or
in plasmids that are transferred between
uh bacteria and they can be really nasty
so let's just say we wanted to identify
the ones that were kind of the worst the
really bad ones so here we're going to
identify the context with the most AMR
genes
so we're selecting uh from the contact
accession and we're using that count and
we're going to rename the count as the
number of genes so that's the number of
rows in micro biggie that return from
this query and then we're also going to
count the number of unique Gene symbols
so we're using this distinct function
now we're going to call that number of
unique genes from micro biggie where
subtype equals a of R so that's just AMR
genes and we're going to use the group
by Clause so we're going to get one row
for every contig accession and then
we're going to sort the results by the
number of genes so we defined num genes
up here and then descending so we get
the the biggest numbers first
um and we're just going to take the top
10. so if we click run
you can see there's these contigs with
lots of AMR genes and this first one
this looks kind of crazy right there's
96 AMR genes on one contig but it looks
a little fishy to me because there's
only 16 unique Gene symbols so that
means they have to some of them have to
have been repeated uh many times and
that seems a little odd so let's take a
look and see what else is on the contigs
that we found in this query
so here here's the query we just ran
um and you know you could run it again
and we're going to use this in what's
called a subquery so we put that query
in parentheses
um and here we're using so we're going
to select all the rows this information
from micro biggie we're renaming micro
biggie uh or aliasing micro biggie to MB
um and then we're going to join that
remember how I said you can join between
tables we're here we're joining to the
results of another query and that other
query is the one we just ran and we're
going to call that top 10 and we're
joining on where the contig accessions
match so we're going to get all of the
entries in micro biggie where that
contig appears in this query we just ran
and then of course we're going to sort
by the number of genes which is what we
did before as well as the position on
the contig just so the genes kind of
come in the order they do on the um
on the Karthik when we click run
we get the results so here's this contig
and you can see it has
um let's make a little more space here
you can see it has uh that 96 genes but
only 16 unique genes
um and if we look down at what those
genes are you can see oh there's this
big run of aph3 prime-1as uh this
doesn't seem really biologically
plausible uh I think um so I think there
may have been an error in the the
assembler got stuck in a loop or
something here so as always you have to
be careful about the data and look at it
um
and I will say this isn't one of our
assemblies okay so let's look at one of
those complex fields so here we're going
to look at that AST phenotypes uh field
that I talked about it's a repeated
record field and we're selecting from
the isolates table and here we're using
another sub query but this time it's in
the where clause and here what we're
going to do is we're going to use this
unnest function to kind of unroll that
repeated field and we're going to count
the number of entries where the
antibiotic is percent penum so we're
looking for carbopenum resistant things
that tested with AST data to be
resistant to carbonoms now carbopenums
of carbopenum antibiotics all end in the
suffix penum so like erdapenum mirapenum
doroopenum Etc and so that makes it easy
to write this query right and then we
want the ones that are resistant and so
when we count those we want where
there's one or more uh res carbon
resistant AST tests for that isolate so
we click run
and you can see the results here and so
there are about 1500 isolates that are
carbopenum we're tested carbon resistant
to one or more carbohydrates
just to get really fancy although I'm
not going to run through it in detail
this is a big query to identify all the
carbo pattern resistant isolates that we
saw before where no mechanism for carbon
pattern resistance was identified the
um
by AMR finder plus so these are carbo
pattern resistant isolates where we
couldn't tell what the the source of the
resistance was um so this would be a
good place to look for novel mechanisms
of resistance and if you click run
you get those results and you can see
these are isolates that are resistant to
one or more carbon atoms
okay and then the last thing I wanted to
do uh was to show you how to get access
to the sequence data and so what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
contig URL there's a contig URL and
protein URL entry in every Row in micro
Biggie and that is kind of an address of
where to get whoops
where to get the sequence data in Google
Cloud so these are in Google Cloud
Storage buckets and here is the address
of the data
um
and I'm going to just use the cloud
shell which is a did I copy that I think
I did not
which is a way to get a Linux prompt
here it is and then we're going to use
gsutil so you could do this from your
own Linux computer as long as you had
the Google Cloud shell utilities
installed and we're going to copy that
URL to the the local directory like that
um and it's going to ask me to authorize
the cloud shell to do to access Google
Cloud for it
and
there we go there's the file we just
downloaded so that's the sequence of the
contig we can
unzip that file and
and look at it and he so here's the
sequence of the contact
UM and this looks like this is a de novo
context so it came from uh
schiza this is not one of the guided
contacts and you can see here's the
sequence and so you can see the same
thing for the protein sequences as well
so that's about all I have time for
right now
um and I think I can go for questions
thanks Sergeant so there's a few
questions in the questions pod a couple
of general questions
first
um what what would you say the
advantages are of using the cloud versus
trying to do these kinds of queries some
other way is the cloud the only way you
can do them
so a lot of the things I showed you you
can do using our web interface but some
of the more complex analyzes you can't
do with the simple search syntax that's
available on the website so that would
be one of the things the other thing is
the micro biggie data that 21 million
rows that are updated daily we don't
have another way to present that data in
bulk other than the web interface so if
you want to do some kind of bulk
analysis that you couldn't do with the
web interface this would be the only way
you could do that the other thing is
that uh this gives you easy access to
all of the content so all of these
assemblies that I'm presenting are
showing in micro biggie are available in
genbank but this is just kind of a more
convenient way to get easy access to
specifically the contigs and and protein
sequences you might be interested in
okay great so so if so those these whole
DM shotgun assemblies that you've made
those are available potentially from our
FTP site as well as they are absolutely
absolutely
okay
um there was another question that
always comes up for these about is it's
about cost
and uh Bill and um Michael felgarden
answered a little bit in the Q a but can
you comment on how much so for example
the queries that you ran sure so uh when
you write a query in uh Google Cloud it
shows you how much data it will process
and Google
um charges based on the amount of data
you process the thing is that the amount
of data we have is very small relative
to their uh costs and they they provide
one terabyte of free search per month
um and so it ends up being that that I
never go over a terabyte you know in
using this stuff so it ends up always
within the free tier but even if I were
to have to pay for it it would be you
know these would be
a few cents at most these queries
I'm going to answer the viral one so
there is a whole other work being done
especially on covid and but I don't know
exactly the extent of all the viral
sequence databases that's a completely
different group at ncbi maybe Peter can
comment on that
yeah so the question is is there an
equivalent process for something like
ncbi viral
um so certainly for the sequences there
is especially for covid uh and then you
know the SARS Kobe 2 sequences so the we
have a website called ncbi virus and
that would be the way to access the
viral data at ncbi
another question that's in here that
hasn't been answered yet is there an API
for the SQL I'm not sure I completely
understand that question so there's
certainly there there is an API for uh
Google bigquery and in several languages
including the command line uh as well
and and you can find information about
that in Google's bigquery documentation
okay and I think somebody asked about
the so you did sure that you have a web
page where people can go to get the
queries that you're using in bigquery
right yes
um I think I linked to it uh here uh
here we are so I put them up here
um but we also in our documentation have
a number of other queries uh so I
encourage you to check out our main
Google Cloud documentation there's a lot
of
many additional queries there that show
you different things you can do and of
course as I said if you still can't
figure things out you feel free to email
us
anyway we can share we'll share that on
the FTP site it's available yes going
through the slides there in the in the
chat as well
all right uh there's some other I have
the Q a open now
so the number of protein genes so these
I we don't have the counted number of
protein genes in each of the assemblies
uh in our tables you can go to genbank
to get that information
uh for any of the assemblies and that's
available also on the FTP site
for the total number of protein genes
how much difference does it make when we
use assembly to identify AMR genes
rather than finding AMR by short reads
only so it depends on your methods
um AMR finder plus is specifically
designed to work on assembled sequence
and so we can take advantage of some
things like an actually annotated
sequence we can take advantage of
protein hmms to be able to better
identify and classify uh novel uh genes
we also because you have the assembled
sequence we can say this is the allele
represented in the assembly and so we're
very
AMR finder plus as I mentioned is kind
of focused on getting the name right and
so we can do that from the assembly it's
not designed to run on reads
I guess that's what I would say the
advantages are
right just sort of a general question
origin and maybe bill would want to
answer this so one of the main points of
the pathogen protection project is to
help the make these associations between
illness outbreaks and the source do we
have any estimate for how many outbreaks
have been solved by this process
well
fda's um said on their website that
they've used the path of detection
system since 2013 for over 1 000 Public
Health actions those don't always mean
outbreaks but it is indicative of both
the frequency of foodborne illnesses and
how often patent detection has been used
and on our home page we have a little
panel over on the side called success
stories and that lists some interesting
Publications uh government websites that
sort of show or highlight very
successful uses of path detection for
various facts
identification of Novel teens
solving outbreaks Etc
very nice yeah so arjun's showing that
now in the slide
questions
I think we've answered the ones that are
open
um
okay well thanks everybody and I will
put these questions together and the
ones that have been answered and put
them in a document and make them
available on that FTP site link
so thanks everybody for coming
and thank you origin and thanks Bill and
Mike for answering questions thank you